there are members of the obama
administration who fully acknowledge
that this happened tommy veter he
tweeted out yeah probably hamas was in
the building but that but still you
shouldn't hit the building
unreal at a certain point it is not
about being pro-palestinian it is about
just being anti-the jewish state
the media continued to be garbage at
their jobs
the right before the jewish holiday of
shiva which is why i was off for the
past
couple of days israel knocked out this
building in gaza which was being used by
hamas
just clearly being used by hamas okay
and the associated press had offices
there now the reason that hamas locates
in buildings with the associated press
there is specifically because they wish
to use the associated press as a shield
this is why because then israel hits an
empty building okay there's no one in
there
they hit the empty building and then the
associated press starts whining to the
world about how terrible it is that
israel would knock down a building
how awful awful that israel would do
this sort of thing except
that israel had apparently showed
smoking gun material classified material
to the us government explaining that
hamas was in the building
okay which is not a shock because hamas
and the associated press
have a covert deal that deal is that
associated press gets to stay in
hamastan so long as it prints hamas
propaganda
and does not print stuff that it knows
about how hamas uses civilians as human
shields
david harsanyi has a good piece over at
national review about this
according to ap ceo gary pruitt he said
his organization
had no indication hamas was in the
building or active in the building he
said this is something we actively
checked to the best of our ability
we would never knowingly put our
journalists at risks this is nonsense
says harsani pruitt knowingly puts
journalists at risk every day he sends
them to places like gaza
but how did pruitt actively check did he
ask hamas did he call the landlord did
you ring the bells
it is of course highly probable that
hamas was using journalists as human
shields
because this is what it does during the
last major outbreak of violence in 2014
gaza shifa hospital became a de facto
headquarters for hamas leaders who could
be seen in the hallways and offices
according to the washington post the ap
did not report that
why because they were working hand in
glove with hamas
in 2014 former ap reporter matty
friedman recounted quote the ap
staff in gaza city would witness a
rocket launch right beside their office
endangering reporters and other
civilians nearby and ap would not report
it
not even in ap articles about israeli
claims that hamas was launching rockets
from residential areas
this happened hamas fighters would burst
into the aps gaza bureau and threaten
the staff
and ap would not report it this also
happened cameraman waiting outside shifa
hospital in gaza would film the arrival
of civilian casualties and then
had a signal from an official turn off
their cameras when wounded and dead
fighters came in helping hamas maintain
the illusion that only civilians were
dying
this do happen the information comes
from multiple sources with firsthand
knowledge of these incidents
now what's incredible about this is that
there are members of the obama
administration who fully acknowledge
that this happened okay there are
members of the obama administration who
fully acknowledge this was probably
being used as a hamas headquarters
okay tommy feeder who worked for barack
obama he didn't just drive his van he
was one of his advisors
he tweeted out yeah probably hamas was
in the building but that but still you
shouldn't hit the building
unreal because at a certain point it is
not
about being pro-palestinian because if
you're pro-palestinian you should not be
pro-hamas
it is about just being anti-the jewish
state and you can sense why okay because
there's a broader left-wing agenda out
there
unfortunately it's what people have
termed accurately the red green alliance
and basically
green being hamas red being communists
there's this long time
feeling on the left that israel is a
colonial state that
israel is an outpost of western
civilization and so many of the people
who are angry at western civilization
are angry at israel they're not angry at
israel
and therefore they're angry in america
they're angry at america and therefore
they're angry at israel or they're angry
at europe and therefore they're angry at
israel so europe
because europe has always had issues
with jews has attempted to separate off
except for a couple of countries right
now like hungary and austria
okay but the reality is that the left
all over the western world
has decided that israel is the bad guy
why because israel is part of this
broader rubric
of hierarchical values the way the left
views the world
is that if you are successful in a
civilized system it is because you have
victimized someone this is the view in
the united states
in the united states from the left the
view is that if you are successful in
the united states it's because you
have white privilege or because the
system was built to accommodate you or
because you have internalized your own
whiteness
and the same thing happens
internationally if there is a group that
is successful
and you can castigate them as white jew
suddenly became white for this purpose
and you can castigate them as white
versus the quote unquote brown
palestinians which is the way that
recited talib talks about this
then that is just another indicator of
hierarchical systems that have to be
torn down which is why you've heard
rashida to leave explicitly say that
she'll say black lives matter is the
same thing
as the palestinians they are not the
same thing for a variety of reasons they
are not the same thing
and for one black lives matter as a
movement last night checked was not
supposed to be firing rockets into
american cities
i was told the black lives matter
movement was distinct from the rioters
and looters if she wants to make a
different claim that's on rashida talib
but it is not a surprise to see black
lives matter supporting hamas they came
out and tweeted yesterday black lives
matter stands in solidarity with
palestinians
we are a movement committed to ending
settler colonialism in all forms and
will continue to advocate for
palestinian liberation
always have and always will be free
palestine by free palestine they don't
mean a separate state of palestine
living alongside in peace and harmony in
jewish states they mean wiping out the
state of israel this has been in the blm
manifesto for quite a while
okay faith for black lives is a group
that put out a letter
to the biden administration trying to
urge biden
not to sell weapons to israel to defend
itself
okay and unfortunately this has infused
a huge percentage of the democratic
party
this this whole perspective has infused
a large percentage of the democratic
party
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic i'd
watch that make it happen gang